le solur décathlon est une compétition
universitaire internationale mise au
point par les Américains au début des
années 2000 par algor lui-même qui
consiste à faire concourir des équipes
d'architecture des équipes d'étudiants
par en architecture et en ingénierie
afin de concevoir l'habitat de demain
cette compétition a lieu tous les 2 ans
elle existe aux États-Unis en Chine mais
aussi en Europe depuis 2010 ici c'est la
première fois en France après deux
éditions espagnoles et vous avez
derrière moi les 20 prototypes qui sont
en en voie d'achèvement ils ont été
construits par les étudiants eux-mêmes
ets seront demain soir tous
fonctionnels il y a à peu près 800 850
personnes derrière moi moyenne d'âge 22
ans une majorité été d'étudiants venant
de toutes ces écoles 16 nationalités
différentes trois
continents c'est un solar Décathlon
solar parce que toute l'énergie
nécessaire au chauffage à l'eau chaude à
la ventilation y compris la mobilité
électrique des habitants est fourni par
le solaire et uniquement par le solaire
Décathlon parce qu'il s'agit de 10
épreuves six d'entre elles jugé par des
plus grands nom de de jury
internationaux trois qui sont des
mesures en fait dans chacun des
prototypes et enfin une sur l'innovation
ce que vous avez derrière moi ce sont
des prototypes d'habitat qui fournissent
pas loin de deux fois tous leurs besoins
de consommation et qui fonctionnent déjà
avec la douche la machine à laver la
cuisine ce sont de véritables habitats
pour la plupart d'ailleurs pas des
maisons mais des tranches
d'immeubles vous êtes en face du
prototype fileas qui a été réalisé par
l'équipe nantaise pour le concours Solar
Descat fond on a réhabilité ce bâtiment
suivant trois concepts d'abord
réinvestir l'existant utiliser au
maximum la matière existante et le réel
ensuite réintroduire l'agriculture en
ville c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que vous
voyez une serre sur le toit symbole de
cette agriculture au sein des villes et
au sein même des bâtiments et mixer les
usages que ce soit au sein du bâtiment
ou au niveau des milieux sociaux et des
générations se faire côtoyer des gens
différents
être ici c'est déjà l'aboutissement d'un
long processus un processus de 18 mois
de travail pour des équipes qui ont été
sélectionnées à l'automne 2012 et qui
ont peu à peu velopp le projet chaque
épreuve donne lie à un prix et celui qui
a eu le plus de points a le Grand Prix
de C
des